now the coalition deal has been sealed
the third conservative social democratic
coalition in the history of West Germany
and United Germany can soon get to work
Angela Merkel remains Chancellor and
says the new government is well equipped
to shape Germany's future whatever
challenges we face we should never
forget that we are here to serve the
people in our country sadena SPD leader
Sigma Gabrielle had a similar message
the government's purpose is to serve the
people of Germany and Europe which
finger does assume this has turned out
to be a grand coalition for ordinary
people people who see that in our
coalition agreement we don't just talk
pie in the sky about grand ideals a
toast to four years of cooperation
between political rivals on the center
right and center left on the CDU side
vassula fond de Lyon becomes defense
minister the first woman to hold the
post volt gang shidler will keep the
finance portfolio Thomas demacia moves
from the defense to the interior
ministry on the SPD side Gabrielle will
be deputy Chancellor and gets a new
economics and energy super ministry and
Frank Votto steinmeier will again become
foreign minister after four years in the
opposition I don't uh sirs becomes state
secretary for immigration refugees and
integration it's the highest office ever
held by a woman from Germany's 3 million
strong ethnic Turkish community on
Tuesday Parliament votes to confirm
angela merkel as chancellor and finally
the ministers will be sworn in